[Musique]
on
m
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 10 février
la france peut-elle passer l'hiver sans
confinement oui pour le gouvernement il
est il existe bien un chemin pour éviter
leur confinement estime son porte-parole
des brigades attal qui précise tout de
même qu'il n'est pas large
les indicateurs de l'épidémie de kobe 19
sont stables voire en légère baisse mais
la propagation des variants inquiète
toujours les médecins outre-rhin le
gouvernement prolonge lui ces
restrictions jusqu'au 7 mars on vient de
l'apprendre comme en france les manois
les infections ralentir mais reste tout
même prudente face aux variants pas de
déconfinement pour l'instant mais des
étapes qui doivent être mises en place
progressivement et prudemment insiste la
chancelière
le passeport vaccinale pour relancer le
tourisme une nouvelle atteinte aux
libertés rupture d'égalité entre les
citoyens l'europe restent divisés sur la
question
le danemark l'islande ou encore
l'estonie s'en font les chantres en
france le débat est prématuré pour
l'exécutif alors que la vaccination
n'est pas obligatoire et qu'elle n'en ai
d'ailleurs qu'à ses prémices les experts
de l'om est toujours opposés à la
vaccination anti covit pour les
voyageurs internationaux joseph bourrel
va proposer aux 27 des sanctions contre
le kremlin une annonce qui intervient
après sa visite à moscou et le camouflet
infligé par la russie le chef de la
diplomatie européenne devrait soumettre
ses propositions aux ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'ue eux lors de
leur réunion le 22 février une adoption
de sanctions qui nécessitent l'unanimité
[Musique]
passera ton l'hiver sans être heureux
confiner la france a franchi hier la
barre des 80 mille morts liés aux
qu'ovide 19 un nouveau conseil de
défense s'est tenue ce matin au tour d'
emmanuel macron suivie par une prise de
parole de gabriella talent le
gouvernement maintient pour l'instant
son cap
on retrouve tout de suite neige
abderrazak en direct de l'elysée bonsoir
nadège le gouvernement qui est droit
dans ses bottes
manifestement kylie mercredi 10 nouveau
conseil de défense sur les crises
sanitaires suivi lui-même d'un conseil
des ministres
absolument un gabriel attal a tenu une
conférence de presse à l'issue de ces
rendez-vous le porte parole du
gouvernement a dit et qu'il existait un
chemin pour éviter leur confinement
les chiffres apparaissent déclinants
depuis ces dernières semaines at il
ajouté alors que rappelez vous il ya une
dizaine de jours elle à l'hypothèse d'un
troisième confinement se voulaient de
plus en plus insistantes
gabriella talent lui même le
porte-parole du gouvernement et bien
avait lui même parlé d'un confinement
serré aujourd'hui laden vous l'aurez
compris a quelque peu changé
il existe bien un chemin pour éviter
leur confinement ce chemin n'est pas
large mais il existe et nous aurions
tort de ne pas tout mettre en oeuvre
pour y parvenir nous sommes toujours sur
le même plateau au même si il apparaît
légèrement déclinant depuis une semaine
il faut évidemment rester extrêmement
prudent la situation reste fragile
il y a par ailleurs des disparités
territoriales face à cette situation
globale et nadège dans le même temps des
scientifiques s'inquiètent d'une poussée
du variant britannique
absolument c'est le cas par exemple du
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses hôpital tenon à paris elle
lui est bien est favorable à un
renforcement des restrictions sanitaires
et un confinement
on observe une poussée incroyable de
jeux variés anglais on nous a dit ce
n'est pas autant que l'angleterre mais
l'île de france est autour de 30 9% de
nouvelles contaminations
on va dans le mur d'un point de vue
strictement sanitaires on ne voit pas
comment on peut échapper un confinement
et l'autre information du journal ech
c'est celle ci locaux vides 19 aurait
été présent en france dès l'automne 2010
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme une
équipe de chercheurs français de
l'institut national de la santé de la
recherche médicale pour aboutir à cette
conclusion ils ont analysé plus de neuf
mille échantillons sanguins collectées
sur les deux cent mille participants
d'une vaste étude épidémiologique sur le
coronavirus la mrc
ces résultats suggèrent que dès les mois
de novembre et décembre le taux de
contamination dans la population
française est déjà de l'ordre d'un cas
pour mille
on semble trouver des cas de manière
sporadique un peu partout sur le
territoire
dans plus de la moitié des cas on a
affaire à des gens qui ont voyagé ou qui
ont été en contact avec des personnes
ayant été malades
l'un des caves et voyager 2 mois en asie
et est revenu début décembre en france
des conclusions qui met à mal est
l'hypothèse d'un départ de l'épidémie au
début du mois de décembre 2019 depuis un
marché de wuhan en chine une tête ce qui
va dans le sens de l'équipe d'experts
chinois et de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms qui juge par ailleurs
hautement improbable la fuite du virus
dans laboratoire et privilégient la
piste d'un animal intermédiaire
à l'origine de la transmission animal
qui pour l'heure n'a pas encore été
identifiée remercier neige à dera sach
en direct donc de l'elysée alors que le
gouvernement maintient son choix pour
l'instant de ne pas re confiné en tout
cas dans le sens strict du terme les
français sont sceptiques vu la
progression des variants sur le
territoire notamment en ile de france
plusieurs syndicats appellent à fermer
des écoles pendant trois voire quatre
semaines tandis que d'autres professions
comme les restaurateurs n'attendent
qu'une chose pouvoir rouvrir alors
confinement ou pas confinement telle est
la question que veulent vraiment les
français c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec benjamin amar
porte parole cgt 94 frédéric jeanjean
secrétaire générale de l'umih 13 bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
alors pas de re confinement pour
l'instant pas d'euro confinement strict
parce que tout dépend la définition
qu'on en ait reconquis finement mais le
gouvernement maintient la pression vu
les chiffres 1 gabriel athènes le porte
parole du gouvernement a déclaré un
adage venez de le dire abderrazak qu'il
existait bien un chemin pour éviter leur
confinement qu'il n'était pas là ce
chemin mais il existait nous aurions
tort de ne pas tout mettre en oeuvre
pour y parvenir est ce que ce chemin
justement emprunté par le gouvernement
frédéric jeanjean c'est à dire le
maintien du couvre-feu s'avoue satisfait
globalement où violences et un semi
confinement qui nous casse les pieds et
qui nous empêchent de travailler on va
être très clair qui est une épidémie on
en est tous conscients
on est tous d'accord sur les problèmes
que rencontre l'ensemble de la planète à
l'heure actuelle nous ce que nous
préconisons aujourd'hui c'est la
réouverture de nos établissements par
les terrasses parce que toutes les
études nous ont dit que en plein air il
ya moins de contamination possible avec
un respect d'un protocole sanitaires
très strictes je vous rappelle que les
protocoles sanitaires mis en place dans
la restauration
nous avons participé nous avons demandé
à les mettre en place
nous allons même initié avec le cahier
de rappelle que le gouvernement refuse
dans un premier temps pour finalement y
venir
donc il s'agit d'être responsable mais
on se retrouve aussi avec des personnes
qui sont en grande détresse et pas
qu'économique
comme jeudi les restaurateurs c'est des
gens qui travaillent 12 à 15 heures par
jour et du jour au lendemain on nous
renvoie la maison sans perspectives
alors on s'est dit à la possibilité de
rouvrir en travaillant sur les terrasses
parce que il ya une grande partie la
france où à l'heure actuelle on peut
commencer à travailler puis on va y
travailler de plus en plus et on se dit
que c'est une piste à étudier à regarder
parce que ça évite les espaces clos
les salles de restaurant et c'est sur
quoi nous nous sommes en train de
travailler en ce moment surtout en ce
moment mais d'ici là vous aurez le temps
certainement de voir les beaux jours
arrivent et alors pendant que ces
restaurateurs un vol rouvrir certains
syndicats demandent à refermer les
écoles parce que les variants on suscite
évidemment de grosses préoccupations
dans les établissements scolaires
benjamin a marre vous voudriez
clairement gros confiné ou pas quelle
est votre position sur le sujet
j'écoutais je vous disais les propos
gabriela talent c'est décidément un
sacré randonneurs parce qu' il aime
beaucoup cette expression sûr nous avons
un chemin est fait de même coup au
moment de la vaccination
nous avons un chemin sur la vaccination
le problème c'est que ce chemin nous
donnent le tournis mais ils donnent le
tournis en fait à l'ensemble des
français
la question que vous posiez c'est que
veulent finalement les français mais en
réalité je pense que les français ils
veulent un peu de cohérence
tout simplement moi j'ai une question
qui est assez qui m'interpelle beaucoup
j'étais moi dimanche rue de rivoli je me
promenais et les magasins les magasins
étaient ouverts
le magasin de vêtements gtrra été ouvert
un magasin de chaussures étaient ouverts
et beaucoup de monde
il y avait beaucoup de monde et moi je
me demandais puisque les grands musées
nationaux ils sont à deux pas il ya le
loup et el milia inquiète yahia musée
d'orsay et puis et ben je sais pas je me
disais mais qu'est ce qui fait que on
est en sécurité lorsqu on est dans le
magasin avec un masque et qu'on achète
une un jean et on n'est pas en sécurité
quand on va au musée avec le même masque
et et on regarde effectivement un
tableau de 2,1 un tableau de rembrandt
ou ou un tableau de 2,2 d'andrea
mantegna je vois pas il n'y a pas de
cohérence en réalité et je pense que
c'est ça et dans ce que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure ça me faisait penser moi
à la à propos par exemple de ce que vous
évoquiez sur sur le fait que désormais
l'épidémie alors été présent dès octobre
ou novembre pas écouté et jusqu'à
présent on a vous avez vu au départ
c'est en janvier puis c'est en décembre
ça me fait penser à la phrase de pascal
vérité ou delà des pyrénées mensonge ans
de ça et bien en fonction des mois et
des semaines les choses varie pas grand
chose en syndicats enseignants dont vous
parlez nous on est cohérent ce que l'on
demande c'est alors on est on n'est pas
obsédé sur la question du confinement
mais on veut que justement il y ait une
une question de sécurité sanitaire qui
soient prises en compte
les variants arrivent ils inquiètent
beaucoup sur leur virulence sur leur
contagion est la seule chance que nous
dit monsieur blanc caire c'est tout va
très bien ouvrez les fenêtres
je viens c'est passé le protocole a été
quand même renforcé en tous les parents
le sac maintenant contient variant sud
africain dans une classe on ferme toute
la classe ans et c'est quand même
devenue la règle
à peu près dans toutes les écoles
françaises on le dit peut-être pas mais
c'est quand même le cas quand on a des
enfants à l'école on le sait alors
écoutez quand on a des enfants à l'école
très bien moi je suis enseignant
stéphanie je suis enseignant et je peux
vous dire faites donc un sondage auprès
des collègues
quels sentiments raison quelle réalité à
changer pour de bon
- dans mon lycée dans mon établissement
scolaire et rien qui a changé et vous
voulez je vous dise pourquoi parce que
la détection des cas contacté des cas
positifs
je peux même pas vous dire qu'il ya des
trous dans la raquette c'est le tamis de
la raquette qui ment voilà j'ai râlé
demandé aux collègues et aux familles
comment ça se passe réellement le riz la
rigueur le sérieux sur la détection des
cas contacts on nous avait dit qu'il
allait avoir des tests de dépistage
massif à l'air pour les as tu encore
entré à la marée alors attendez attendez
deux minutes alors à la rentrée très
bien donc la question qui se pose c'est
qu'on nous avait dit que ça allait vous
vous souvenez ça allait reposer sur les
médecins scolaires
je vais vous dire un truc moi les
médecins scolaires en 20 ans de carrière
j'en ai vu autant que des licornes
voilà donc on est sur des études
annoncent la réalité de la situation
sanitaire en france depuis le mois de
septembre elle était en permanence
minimisée par le ministère et ceux qui
ce qui ferait qu'on ferait sécurisé
quelque part ce serait cette question de
comment on détecte les cas contactez les
cas positifs mais ça honnêtement c'est
pas du tout rigoureux alors où ce qu'on
dit depuis le début c'est bon sens
situation exceptionnelle moyen
exceptionnel c'est pas forcément le
confinement mais c'est réquisition de
bâtiments recrutement de 2 comment dire
de personnel c'est une situation
d'urgence on fait exactement avec les
mêmes moyens que d'habitude et on
explique que tout va très bien mais
franchement qui on veut convaincre en
tout cas effectivement oui on va donner
aussi la parole à frédéric jeanjean tout
de même
la sonnette d'alarmé ce sont les
médecins parfois qu'il attire plus que
le gouvernement qui entend temporiser un
scientifique science met un gilles
pialoux on a déjà des razak le site est
également chef du service des maladies
infectieuses à l'hôpital tenon à paris
qui dit en gros on a une poussée
incroyable de ce variant anglais 39% des
nouvelles contaminations en
ile-de-france situation alarmante sur le
strict point de vue sanitaire je ne vois
pas comment on peut échapper un
confinement nous dit il certaines
certains dénoncent leur haine des
médecins trop alarmiste dans le débat
public c'est votre cas frédéric jeanjean
ce parce que en attendant les
restaurations et restaurateurs pardon et
les hôtels ne sont pas ouverts alors
qu'on espagne 1 on l'a pas évoqué tout à
l'heure mais en espagne en retrouvant
les restaurants on va être clair moi
j'entends ce que disent les médecins
j'aurais tendance à leur faire confiance
je me méfie par contre des analyses
statistiques dans ce cadre une
statistique on lui fait dire ce que l'on
veut dans une étude faite par l'institut
pasteur qui ont fait état une étude et
un sondage on dit ce qu'on veut donc là
dessus moi je reste assez circonspect
mais je fais confiance aux médecins
je fais confiance aux scientifiques le
président de la république leur fait
confiance
il aura même laissé les clefs du
gouvernement pendant des mois
ce qui est étonnant c'est quoi notre
j'avais un médecin en espagne qui nous
disait ici même sur ce plateau devant
mon étonnement à la réouverture des
restaurants que là-bas y avait des
études qui tendrait à prouver que et ben
le nombre de contaminations dans les
restaurants espagnols n'étaient pas si
grand donc on se demande évidemment dont
sur quelles études on se base est là
qu'elle vivrait sur tout mais c'est ce
que je vous disais l'étude qui nous a
été présentée comme une étude de
l'institut pasteur était un sondage est
peut-être que les gens ont répondu ce
que on attendait qu'il réponde aussi
parce une véritable étude il n'y en a
pas il ya eu ce protocole de chicago des
états unis mais on n'a aucune étude
sérieuse
à l'heure actuelle on nous a balancé non
fumage avec l'histoire institut pasteur
pendant l'hiver mais qui n'est rien du
tout nous préconisons com ouvre les
terrasses on voit les gens mangent et se
sont regroupés dans les bureaux le midi
son angers côte à côte sur des bornes
soit se mettre sur les trottoirs j'ai
même vu des gens qui les prennent un
carton pizza manger sur une poubelle et
aux maudits qui font ça parce qu'il
n'est pas tendre pour s'appuyer
parce que c'est un gars une crise
sanitaire alors si on met des tables si
on est des chaises qui peut manger un
plat chaud sans dire comment faire la
fiesta la bamboche on dit pardon
gouvernement eh bien écoutez il s'assoit
ils peuvent manger
simplement ça permet d'avoir un temps
pour manger pour ceux qui sont en
déplacement professionnel
ça permet de pouvoir travailler un
moment ce qui manque c'est pas forcément
que de la cohérence de ce que disait
monsieur tout à l'heure c'est aussi
beaucoup de bon sens ce qui se passe
dans la vraie vie ce qui se passe avec
les français au quotidien ce que vous
voyez dans votre établissement quand
vous enseigner ce que nous voyons dans
la rue sur nos terrasses et au quotidien
et dans tous les commerces ont été pour
connaître ce concert on est que bell a
cédé france est clairement on n'est pas
assez sur le terrain il faudrait
peut-être donner le pouvoir aux élus
dans les régions sur le terrain c'est ce
qui manque clairement aujourd'hui en
france frédéric jeanjean
mais c'est qu'il faudrait d'abord les
écouter les élus sur le terrain
quand vous voyez les fonctionnements les
ars qui arrivent et qui ceux qui se
comportent comme des préfets maintenant
il devrait plutôt travailler localement
on est une étude par département par
région qu'on ait une approche qui soient
locales et qui serait peut être plus
efficace parce que si les comportements
d'après ce qu'on a bien compris qu'il
faut qu'on se transmet le virus
donc c'est à partir de ces études là
qu'on arriverait à quelque chose de
cohérent a à proposer des solutions
région avant car ce débat
si vous voulez pardonnez moi messieurs
vous interroger sur un autre sujet qui
fait débat en ce moment ça concerne la
vaccination ils passent par vaccinale on
va regarder tout d'abord ces chiffres du
site kobe tracker avant d'en discuter
regarder près de 2 millions
deux personnes à peu près ont reçu une
première dose à peine 300 milles ont
reçu la deuxième dose kobe tracker qui
en tire cette analyse cela fait des
semaines que nous dit et qu'on nous dit
que le vaccin c'est la clé un nouveau
donc débat qui prend de l'ampleur le
passeport vaccinale pour retrouver notre
liberté vous êtes pour ou contre
benjamin a marre vous qui avez ulcos vie
d'un mais oui tout à fait ridicule
coheed et qui sait que cette maladie est
une infamie quand on compte selon la
source interne aux graves
c'est une véritable peste mais moi je
suis un fervent partisan de la
vaccination mais mais en l'occurrence
moi je ne comprends pas ces polémiques
lancées par certains ont ça serait déjà
bien qu'on arrive à protat à vacciner
ceux qui le veulent
voyez vous ce serait déjà bien qu'on
arrive à faire ça qu'on ait une
logistique correct voilà parce que on
est dans le flou le plus complet alors
l'âge
j'entendais qu'il y avait des doutes sur
le vaccin astrazeneca
c'est quoi que il ya déjà une campagne
de vaccination correct qu'on arrive à
vacciner ceux qui le souhaitent dans des
rythmes adéquate et ensuite on évoquera
d'autres débats mais si vous voulez y a
rien qui va
c est en fait sur le vaccin mais comme
sur le reste il ya rien qui tient c'est
pour ça que j'ai insisté sur la notion
de cohérence
on vient d'apprendre que il fallait que
les que les masques comment dire de
tissus était inadéquat nous dans
l'éducation à la rentrée on nous en a
distribué fièrement donc moi j'aimerais
qu'on avant d'avoir ce genre de grands
débats et qui vole haut niveau des
éperviers des aigles que déjà on arrive
à avoir une gestion un tant soit peu
carré des problèmes qui se posent au
moment t voyez vous donc il est là le
problème
moi l'eau en l'occurrence je me suis
renseigné un petit peu pour savoir en
fonction de ma situation quand est ce
que je pourrais être vaccinés enfin ce
sera pas ce ne sera pas avant la fin
mars début avril
donc de quoi on parle avant de polluer
le débat et de parler de ce genre de
choses qui eux mêmes bien évidemment à
pasqua un passeport vaccinale bien sûr
que va ça va susciter légitimement plein
de débat autour de la liberté etc
mais au lieu de polluer le débat qu'on
arrive juste à vacciner correctement
ceux qui le souhaitent et visites
le mans il ya des millions de personnes
oui encore jamais à mars avril 12 est
optimiste je croisais une une dame tout
à l'heure dans la rue de 85 ans qui se
lamentaient qu'elle était elle avait son
premier rendez vous le 2 mai 1 voilà et
c'était ça semble être à un gros
problème frédéric jeanjean côté
vaccination vous même constat que
benjamin marronnage un petit peu dans
l'incohérence permanente
non c'est pas de l'incohérence c'est un
système kafkaïen
les technocrates ont pris le pouvoir
vous savez moi j'ai ma belle famille qui
est dans l'ariège j'ai mes beaux parents
qui ont 86 et 77 ans ils sont
prioritaires pour être vaccinés mais ya
pas de vaccin dans l'ariège
donc pour l'instant c'est pas possible
on va voir quand ça va être envisageable
moi je vois je vois ces exemples un peu
partout c'est bien beau de parler du
passeport vaccinale encore faudrait-il
que les vaccins encore faut-il qu'ils
soient effectivement mis en place après
on demande ce serait bien aussi de
vérifier aux frontières on vient à peine
de s'y mettre pour les gens qui arrivent
j'ai un confrère l'inquiéter à dakar au
mois d'octobre
il est arrivé il m'a dit que j'irais là
car je suis sorti de l'avion
immédiatement lui a fait le test 24
heures à l'hôtel il a fallu attendre et
vérifié il est revenu à marseille
provence à marignane
il arrivait de dakar il est sorti de
l'avion il est allé chercher sa valise
et a fait son taxi il est rentré chez
lui et personne ne rien demander et même
dedans vous diront passeport vaccinale
mais un moment il va falloir se mettre à
réfléchir et à travailler avec cohérence
avec bon sens
il va falloir que les choses soient
faites non plus par rapport aux sondages
parce que c'est par rapport aux sondages
comme ça on fixe la stratégie maintenant
parce que vous avez 40 % des français
qui sont pas être confinée et 60
concerts qui sont pas d'accord et c'est
pour ça que l'on sent l'on change de
discours au niveau du gouvernement
et bien c'est insupportable c'est pas
les statistiques ni les sondages qui
vont arriver et qui vont dicter notre
quotidien merci à tous les deux
benjamins mahfad eric jean-jean d'avoir
porté votre voix et peut-être que le
gouvernement viendra vous vous consulter
sait-on jamais merci à tous les deux ont
bien vu
et si la situation ne tient qu'à un fil
en france l'allemagne el sayeh a décidé
de prolonger ses restrictions jusqu'au 7
mars selon un projet d'accord entre une
gueule à merkel et les dirigeants des 16
länder du pays
les restrictions sanitaires programmée
jusqu'au 14 février sont prolongées
jusqu'au 7 mars
pour la chancelière une sortie
prématurée du confinement partiel
risquerait de faire repartir le nombre
d'infections très vite à la hausse et
pour plus de précisions le retrouvons
tout de suite au peter oliver
correspondant berthet à berlin bonsoir
peter oliver merci d'être avec nous
alors réunion aujourd'hui entre la
chancelière et les régions est
manifestement c'est un gars la mer kalki
qui l'emportent puisque les restrictions
vont être prolongées jusqu'au 7 mars
qu'elle voulait que les restrictions
contre lui jusqu'au 14 mars
c'est un combat entre les deux il s'est
agi d'un débat très âpre comme la part
des oignons et entre le gouvernement
fédéral et entre les chefs de cet état
fédéral allemand bien comportée que
quand une drive
pour la ministre président lee palatin
la chancellerie comme ne sont pas
intéressés incapable d'écouter la
population est brisé
ces restrictions projets de résolutions
a été publié au l'astre des registres
locaux venus en aide aux proches que la
marque au late show et le
vice-chancelier sera pour les
sociaux-démocrates 7 aux prochaines
élections non elle ces compliments ont
disparu du document final discuter le
résultat des discussions donc
apparemment on ne les pas de ses
excréments et il ya beaucoup de flou
concernant l'échec des responsables donc
il y avait aucun trottoir et non mais
semble que la chancellerie et donner
beaucoup plus qu'ils n'ont gagné cette
fois ci alors les régions peuvent a
décidé en tout cas indépendamment de
rouvrir plutôt les écoles et les crèches
c'était une mesure phare peut-être pour
faire passer la pilule grande victoire
pour beaucoup de retard sur tous ses
états le nombre de décès dus à la cour
icônes sont très bas et d'autres vont
rouvrir les écoles dès lundi prochain
cela va être très rapide ça reste que la
merkel et les dirigeants des états sont
tombés d'accord pour dire que ce sera
aux états de décider quand les écoles et
les crèches ou ouvreur mais certains
états ne sont pas contentes comme les
bade wurtemberg leur ministre président
a suggéré
indiqué qu'il s'agissait selon lui d'
une très mauvaise idée le compromis mais
c'est que les professeurs et
l'administration et des écoles seront
favorisés quant à la vaccination
auparavant il était prévu qu'il
recevrait les axes avec les personnes b
soit un temps plus et ils vont
maintenant être vaccinés en étant que
les personnes âgées de soixante dix
plutôt que de 81 ans qu'ils seront les
prochains à être vaccinés les écoles
rouvriront dès lundi vous parliez peter
oliver du chapitre vaccination justement
en allemagne on est très agacé par la
lenteur de cette campagne de vaccination
alors que c'est quand même un petit peu
mieux qu'en france
l'acceptabilité est encore possible en
allemagne sur ce plan là
des problèmes au sein de la classe
politique et au sein du public
jens par le ministre de la santé il ya
deux semaines à disait que l'allemagne
avait dix semaines de retard par rapport
aux projections pour le déploiement du
vaccin
les gens ils sont entre nos mains nous
ne nous retrouvons dans des villes comme
berlin par exemple avec des centres de
vaccination sans vaccin et donc cela
rend impossible des flamands de mardi
dans l'infrastructure a été mise en
place ce sont des doses qui manquent pas
qu'il ya de la frustration le consensus
est toujours que il faut leur entrée
dans le programme de vaccination
européen
le vaccin pour tous mais en tout cas
effectivement les gens commencent à être
agacé par la lenteur de du programme de
vaccination
merci beaucoup plus tard oliver
correspondante berthet à berlin pour
toutes ces précisions
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du bâtiment vaccine and
est il vraiment la solution pour
relancer le tourisme mais à quel prix et
puis nous parlerons de josep borrell le
chef de la diplomatie qui va proposer
aux 27 des sanctions contre le kremlin
une annonce qui intervient après sa
visite à moscou et le camouflet infligé
par la russie avec en creux la sphère
navali
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos pays
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
oh
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez la
stratégie vaccinale menées au sein de
l'union européenne
ursula von der leyen s'en est expliqué
sous le feu des critiques face à la
lenteur des campagnes de vaccination
partout en europe
la présidente de la commission a rendu
des comptes ce matin aux eurodéputés
ursula von der leyen a reconnu des
retards et des erreurs mais elle assure
que sa méthode est bien la bonne nous
avons fait le choix de ne pas prendre de
raccourcis en matière de sécurité ou
d'efficacité nous assumons ce choix
pleinement
il n'y a pas de compromis à faire
lorsqu'il s'agit d'injecter une
substances biologiquement actives
j'ai une personne en bonne santé et
c'est pourquoi nous nous appuyons sur le
processus de contrôle de les mains
notre agence européenne de médicaments
oui cela veut dire l'approbation prend
trois à quatre semaines supplémentaires
il ce temps supplémentaire est un
investissement essentiel pour la
confiance et la sécurité
mais oui il ya également des leçons à
tirer de ce processus et nous le faisons
déjà entre milieux nous devons améliorer
le partage de données des essais
cliniques avec les mains et c'est
pourquoi nous lançons dès maintenant à
nouveau réseau européen d'essais
cliniques et retour en images sur les
dysfonctionnements de la stratégie
vaccinale européenne le 27 décembre
dernier les 27 pays de l'union
européenne lancent conjointement leurs
campagnes de vaccination
la présidente de la commission
européenne mire cela vendeurs leyen
affirme sur twitter c'est le moment pour
l'europe
pourtant au 3 février cette campagne de
vaccination européenne ressemble à un
échec
seulement 3% de la population de l'union
européenne avait reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin un pourcentage loin derrière
israël les états unis et le royaume uni
pourquoi lieu est plus lente
la faute tout d'abord aux précautions
prises par l'union européenne
contrairement aux britanniques et aux
israéliens lui a voulu que les
laboratoires soient responsables
juridiquement des effets secondaires des
vaccins
l'union européenne a également voulu
attendre le rapport complet de l' agence
européenne du médicament avant de donner
son feu vert pour une mise en
circulation
et puis la question du prix des vaccins
a donné lieu à de longues négociations
conséquence les vingt-sept se sont
retrouvés englués dans des retards de
livraison
la commission européenne a donc été
obligé de revoir ses objectifs à la
baisse
ursula von der leyen le reconnaît
elle-même l'europe n'était pas prête
pour la production de vaccins en masse
en regardant dans le rétroviseur nous
aurions dû plus penser à la production
de masse et aux défis qu'elle pose
nous aurions dû mettre en garde en
expliquant qu'au début le processus ne
serait pas fluide qu'il y aurait des
hauts et des bas au total l'union
européenne accumule cinq semaines de
retard sur son programme
un délai qui coûterait près de 90
milliards d'euros selon l'assureur
allianz
problème ces 90 milliards représentent
un montant supérieur au versement du
fonds de relance de cette année lieu
vise désormais sur la distribution de
100 millions de doses durant le premier
trimestre 2001 21 soit moitié moins
qu'initialement prévu au deuxième
trimestre de cette année
l'union européenne visera 300 millions
de doses voire 80 millions de plus si le
sérum de johnson and johnson est
autorisée alors qu'ursula vanderlei
année sous le feu des critiques
emmanuel macron et angela merkel sont
montés au créneau pour défendre la
présidente de la commission
ils ont également réaffirmé leur soutien
à la stratégie vaccinale européenne et
les vaccins qui soulève une autre
question faut-il imposer un verre un
passeport vaccinale pour relancer le
tourisme c'est ce que propose en tout
cas israël
et la grèce les deux pays ont annoncé
lundi un accord permettant à leurs
citoyens respectifs de voyager sans
aucune restriction sanitaires ni
quarantaine au faire simple il leur
faudra uniquement présenté une preuve de
leur vaccination un passeport avec senna
je ne fait pas l'unanimité au sein de
l'union européenne la france et
l'allemagne sont encore réticents
florian lambert un éventuel passeport
vaccinale qui divise au sein de l'union
européenne plusieurs états membres ont
en effet annoncé le lancement d'un
passeport de vaccination contre le
comique 19
mais l'idée ne plaît pas à tout le monde
parmi les pays réticents
la france l'allemagne ou encore la
pologne qui jugent sa mise en oeuvre
encore prématuré en cause le manque de
recul sur l'efficacité du vaccin sur les
nouveaux variants le spectre d'une
ségrégation médical et un risque
potentiel d'atteintes aux libertés
malgré sa ferme opposition à un
passeport vaccinale généralisée
l'allemagne n'exclut pas cette
éventualité dans le secteur privé
si un restaurateur veut faire une offre
uniquement destiné aux personnes
vaccinées
il sera difficile de l'interdire dans le
cadre juridique actuel
si l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale n'est
pour l'heure pas ratifié au sein de
l'union européenne
certains états membres prennent déjà des
dispositions dans ce sens la suède et le
danemark ont par exemple annoncé la mise
en place de certificats électroniques de
vaccination destinée aux voyages à
l'étranger à des événements sportifs ou
culturels voire à des établissements de
restauration dans le cas danois des
position également partagée par l'italie
et l'espagne qui plaide pour un retour à
une vie normale au plus vite
de son côté l'organisation mondiale de
la santé se dit favorable au principe de
certificat de vaccination mais se montre
critique sur la mise en place de
passeports indispensable pour tout
voyage nous ne savons toujours pas si
les personnes vaccinées peuvent
continuer à être affectés peuvent
transmettre la maladie en europe 12
millions de personnes ont reçu une
première dose soit 2 7% de la population
peut-être pas encore suffisant
pour proposer le fameux sésame à
l'échelle continentale et pour parler de
ce passeport vaccinale nous sommes en
direct depuis new york avec james
asquith fondateur de valider soit plate
forme de partage de maisons entre
particuliers c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
james merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france avant la grève sans israël
qui viennent donc de signer un accord
touristique permettant à leurs citoyens
respectifs ayant été vaccinés contre le
coc vide de voyager sans restriction
dans ces deux pays c'est la solution
selon vous pourriez vous s'il vous plaît
à répéter alors je disais donc la grèce
et israël j'espère que vous m'entendez
bien voilà qui ont signé cet accord sur
le passeport vaccinale ils pourront les
grecs et les israéliens voyager sans
restriction s'ils se font vacciner
contre le coc vide
est ce que pour vous c'est aujourd'hui
la bonne solution
je pense que nous allons voir cela de
plus en plus au cours des années à venir
une bulle entre deux pays qui ont qui se
sont conformés aux procédures de
vaccination au niveau du pourcentage
vaccination solde de personne qui se
targue d'être scientifique sans être
qualifié d opinion sur les vaccins le
fait qu'ils aient c'est qu'avec la
progression de la vaccination y aura ces
bulles de plus en plus donc
effectivement il ya déjà une bulle avec
hong kong et on parle également du
passeport vaccinale et je pense que cela
va être le chemin à suivre
alors on l'a vu l'europe notamment est
très divisé sur le sujet notamment en
france où on est carrément réticents
enfin il faut dire quand même
on n'arrive pas à vacciner beaucoup en
ce moment donc ça sera un débat dans un
deuxième temps sans vouloir être cynique
est-ce que selon vous on y viendra
nécessairement il faut bien faire des
pcr pour voyager vous en savez quelque
chose puisque vous avez effectué un jeu
précise plus de 140 vols à l'année
dernière je crois que vous êtes celui
qui est le plus voyagé sur la planète
apparemment et plus de 60 tests pcr
l'année dernière donc en gros est-ce que
forcément on y viendra à ce passeport
vaccinale comme on le fait aujourd'hui
avec les pcr la façon dont les gens
voyagent va changer beaucoup de
personnes n'ont pas peur des vols
internationaux et je pense que cette
attitude va rester pendant moins deux
ans donc le niveau et du vol
international à rester bas pour cinq ou
six ans et j'ai constaté beaucoup de
changements au cours des douze mois
effectivement comment les lotos les
tests pcr les restrictions dans les
différents pays
j'espère que d'ici à fin en fin de l'été
à la fin de cette année les restrictions
seront assouplies et qu'on va retrouver
la souveraineté des frontières et que
les gens pourront à nouveau se dépasser
dur en australie notamment au cours de
l'année passée j'avais moins de
restrictions ne vive plus normalement
entrer dans le pays où un sortir est
devenu quasiment impossible
la quarantaine de deux semaines en 30
ans sortant et le contrôle des
frontières est vraiment très très tous
et les européens qui peuvent ses
fondations ce que m
et en matière sanitaire donc je pense
que les vols domestiques seront bien
plus important dans l'avenir proche mais
je pense qu'il y aura toujours des
contrôles aux frontières a qui pourrait
même continuer au cours des alliances du
vote les états d'être certain de qui
rentrent sur le territoire vous parlez
du scepticisme autour des vaccins et
c'est vrai qu'en france il y en a un
réel même s'il tend à régresser la part
des français qui ne souhaite pas se
faire vacciner en tout cas qui sont très
sceptiques et quand même encore
importante
clairement vous le professionnel du
tourisme vous pensez qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont réticents à voyager qui
le sauront même une fois vacciner ça
reste du domaine du possible qu'il y ait
vraiment un avant et un après si l'on
peut dire mais je ne suis pas un
scientifique et son opinion sur les
vaccins ce qui suit 1 pour ceux qui sont
mauvais donc je ne peux pas vraiment
mettre ma pierre à l'édifice
je n'ai pas vraiment la compétence je
pense que nous en sommes à un stade où
beaucoup de personnes vivent confinés
depuis longtemps et encore il ne semble
pas devoir disparaître avant longtemps
quelque chose doit changer pour moi à
moins que les gens souhaitent vivre
comme ça lui pour toujours alors les
vaccins c'est le seul moyen d'avancer
les experts scientifiques parlent
également de paracétamol d'autres
médicaments
on les accepte je ne vois pas pourquoi
est ce que les vaccins soirée eux
acceptable tu me manques les experts qui
collait soutiennent pour moi il n'y a
pas d'autre solution
il ya un an où il nous a fait penser que
dans 2 3 secondes de confinement
réussirez à arrêter la contamination
mais ce n'est pas comme ça que c'est
arrivé quelque chose doit changer et
pour moi c'est le vaccin on l'a dit vous
avez fait donc 140 vols c'est beaucoup
l'année dernière est ce qu'il y à des
pays où la gestion de l'actif du cornât
virus vous a frappé
est ce que c'est vraiment différent en
fonction de là où on voyage dans le
monde au niveau des restrictions des
libertés individuelles est ce que ça
varie beaucoup et il est très
intéressant de voir la façon dont les
pays ont évolué au cours du processus
également je me rappelle tous voyagé
dans certains pays ou ont testé à
l'arrivée ce qui ne marchait pas du tout
donc ça a été vraiment un processus sans
grand huit certains pays ont bien mieux
géré que d'autres certains ont dit qu'on
doit soutenir les économies on doit
soutenir les commerces certains pays ou
un système sanitaire très solide
je suis moi-même un économiste et on ne
peut pas se fier que à la sainte et il
faut adopter des approches pragmatiques
face à une telle situation
je me suis rendu au ghana l'année
dernière pour le travail il y avait des
tests de 15 minutes à l'arrivée et sexy
j'ai également un test pcr je suis aux
états unis et aux états unis tous les
états font différemment à la essaie de
se rouvrir au tourisme et demande
également de test pcr ainsi qu'une
quarantaine de trois jours et adresses
de l'esr à la sortie une quarantaine de
deux semaines où une quarantaine en
hôtel par exemple comme le visage de
droit ni ce n'est pas tenable pour des
gens qui le faire des séjours très très
court de deux ou trois jours par exemple
donc je pense que certains pays approche
adoptée nous approche plus réaliste
baissé à l'entrée pcr à la sortie et une
quarantaine dont on peut sortir après un
test négatif la meilleure approche pour
moi quand je sais c'est à garder autant
que possible l'économie offerte
et je pense que le tourisme aura
beaucoup souffrir du pendant un certain
temps mais j'espère que plus tard cette
année nous ferons tout changement vers
un tourisme régional et domestiques
il ya en lui en france sur dans les
autres pays on ne pouvait se dire
prendre des vacances en france passé de
paris au sud de la france s'est un peu
ennuyé en ville pourrait faire ça à
n'importe quel moment alors que se
rendre à bali par exemple c'est vraiment
intéressant
maintenant on n'a plus cette possibilité
m'a confié ce confinement
je pense que n'importe qui serait très
heureux de pouvoir aller simplement à la
plage ne serait ce que pour un week end
dans le même pays ça devient intéressant
parce que c'est une expérience qu'on n'a
plus que peut-être que cette forme de
tourisme va se développer c'est un monde
qu'aux gens pourront plus en profiter
en tout cas il est certain que les
frontières vont rester fermés au moins
jusqu'à l'année prochaine cela aura une
influence sur les habitudes merci
beaucoup de jeunes ça squeeze son
fondateur de valider soit pas de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse merci à vous
dans le reste de l'actualité et regain
de tensions entre moscou et bruxelles le
chef de la diplomatie de l'ue appelle à
des sanctions contre la russie de retour
d'une visite à moscou josette borel a
dénoncé une confiance qui ne règnent
plus le dialogue politique est dans
l'impasse selon lui à faire n'avait ni
choix géostratégique du gouvernement
russe ou encore expulsions de diplomates
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
claireaux depuis son retour à bruxelles
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
s'est montré plus pressant plus incisif
envers la russie
dans un discours face au parlement
européen il s'est dit je cite préoccupé
par les perspectives des choix
géostratégiques des autorités russes et
de leurs implications pour l'europe et
pour le peuple russe
de quoi l'inciter à proposer de
nouvelles sanctions contre moscou pour
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères
c'est malheureusement ce à quoi on
s'expose quand on tente de mener une
politique étrangère non alignés
hobson off comme nolwenn vous voyez
quelle est l'évolution de la situation
sur la scène internationale toute
tentative de la russie de devenir
autonome et de faire valoir son droit à
une politique étrangère indépendante à
la protection du droit international se
heurte à une opposition de plus en plus
féroce de la part de ceux qui parmi nos
collègues occidentaux cherchent à nous
rendre en fin de compte docile à nous
faire accepter les interprétations assez
douteuse et valeurs humaines
universelles qu'il professe eux mêmes et
qui sont contraires à la tradition
culturelle russe à nos traditions
civilisationnel et veulent que la russie
soit en fin de compte un territoire
commode pour la promotion de leurs
propres intérêts dans le domaine de la
sécurité ainsi que sur le plan
économique politique et social
hop suisse nos politiques il ya aussi eu
les expulsions prévisible de trois
diplomates russes en réponse au renvoi
de trois diplomates
un suédois un polonais et un allemand le
5 février dernier accusé d'avoir
participé à un rassemblement en soutien
alexeï navalni enfin pour en revenir aux
menaces de sanctions contre la russie
celles ci seront discutées à l'occasion
de la réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne le 22
février puis lors d'un sommet le 3 mars
prochain
la visite de joseph bourrel n'aura donc
pas permis de réamorcer le dialogue
entre moscou et bruxelles
bien au contraire oui pour en parler
nous sommes avec l'autre blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir que deux saisons merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
visite de joseph bourrel en russie la
semaine dernière était prévu de longue
date un sound c'est le chef de la
diplomatie européenne qui a choisi la
maintenir on en parlait ensemble la
dernière fois mais le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe sergueï lavrov
quel intérêt avait t-il a finalement à
maintenir lui cette rencontre je crois
d'abord qu'il a voulu honorer un
rendez-vous qu'il avait pris avec le
représentant d'une institution
importante importante pour le président
poutine importante pour les russes
puisque c'est toujours le premier
partenaire économique de la russie
bien sûr le partenariat avec la chine
monte lentement y compris dans le
domaine économique mais pour le moment
c'est l'union européenne qui reste le
principal partenaire économique
alors bien sûr monsieur lavrov savez
bien que monsieur borel allait soulever
la question de la faire là navalni
d'abord parce que mon rêve monsieur
monsieur monsieur bord elles
représentent 27 et amant et que les
opinions publiques de ses 27 états
membres avaient été un peu choqué par
l'empoisonnement de la vanille puis par
sa mise en prison
donc il était prévu qu'il en parle j'en
à parler bien sûr monsieur lavrov avait
parlé avait préparé une batterie
d'arguments pour disqualifier
l'intervention l'intervention européenne
la vie de l'union européenne sur cette
affaire et monsieur borel et bien
il est resté stoïque devant cette
batterie d'intervention devant cette
salve et finalement il est passé à autre
chose c'est-à-dire aux sujets sur
lesquels il y à des coopérations avec la
russie qui pourrait d'ailleurs se
développer qu'il s'agisse de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
qu'il s'agisse de la lutte contre la
pandémie et des problèmes sanitaires en
général qu'il s'agisse aussi des
questions énergétiques et qu'il s'agisse
des questions économiques en général
par conséquent évidemment les
journalistes ensuite nous retenu que le
sujet était le plus le plus chaud était
le plus le plus litigieux
c'est à dire la sphère davani et on n'a
parlé que de la sphère navalni alors
justement pourquoi la presse européenne
fustige-t-elle autant joseph bourrel
je crois pourtant à raison la première
raison c'est que josette borel est allé
à moscou en dépit des avis des états
membres qu'ils visionnent pas y aller
la pologne là les états baltes et il y
est allé sans tenir compte également de
des conseils des américains qui lui
disait de ne pas y aller et des conseils
de l'otan qui visait qu'il ne fallait
pas y aller il a donc passé outre l'avis
des gens qui considèrent que la russie a
pris un cours hostile aux pays
occidentaux et que par conséquent il
faut l'isoler et les prolongements d'un
avis contraire en tout cas et est allé
voir sur place ce qu'il en était et puis
le deuxième le deuxième élément de cette
critique c'est que les journaux
occidentaux ont volontiers caricaturer
monsieur morel comme finalement un grand
naïf qui allait se jeter dans la gueule
du loup
c'est à dire qu'ils allaient discuter
avec un diplomate formée à l'époque
soviétique ça a été écrit par beaucoup
de journaux qui en effet a beaucoup
d'expérience et peut parfois jouer au
chat et à la souris avec ses
interlocuteurs
et puis enfin le troisième type de
critique c'est la critique de ceux qui
toujours prédisent l'effondrement de
l'union européenne
et qui sont des déclinistes qui pensent
que les états membres principaux l'union
européenne sont en voie de déclin donc
bord elle s'est trouvée sous la critique
conjugué de ces trois familles de pensée
politique si on peut dire
et effectivement eh bien il doit
aujourd'hui faire face alors que
blanchemaison la relation entre l'europe
et la russie dans ce contexte est elle
condamnée à être conflictuelle certains
pays il aimerait bien il est clair qu
aux états unis et en chine
on ne souhaite pas un rapprochement
entre l'europe et la russie dans ce
grand jeu quadrangulaire entre les états
unis la chine la russie et l'europe
eh bien il ya là un enjeu considérable
du côté russe
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas
puisque vladimir poutine
il ya peu de temps au mois de janvier
s'exprimant par visioconférence au forum
de davos a expliqué combien la russie et
est européenne et il a dit c'est à
l'europe de jouer mais nous sommes pas
allés beaucoup plus loin avec l'europe
alors du côté européen maintenant du
côté de l'union européenne il ya
effectivement deux camps il ya un conte
qui considèrent que l'europe que l'union
pardon que la russie a pris un autre
cours qu'elle tourne le dos aux valeurs
européennes qu'elle regarde plutôt vers
l'asie et finalement un courant hérité
des néo conservateurs américains qui
considèrent qu'il faut isoler la russie
et qu'il ne faut pas coopérer avec elle
et puis l'autre courant qui au contraire
considèrent qu' il y a beaucoup
d'intérêt commun entre l'europe et la
russie que et que et que de toute
manière un jour ou l'autre
l'europe et la russie retrouveront la
voie d'une coopération fondamental parce
que c'est écrit dans la géographie et
dans l'histoire et puis il ya peut-être
une troisième catégorie et d'ailleurs
qui considère que la france et
l'allemagne devraient en tout cas montré
la voie et aller dans le sens de ces
coopération seller peut-être ce qui est
en train de se passer sur north stream 2
puisque si je comprends bien
madame merkel n'est pas d'humeur à céder
sur ce projet dont elle considère qu'il
est essentiel pour la transition
énergétique de l'allemagne et de
l'europe
donc monsieur bord n va faire rapport
comme ça tu es vivant votre sujet au
conseil des affaires étrangères de la
fin du mois probablement que les avis
divergeront mais peut-être aussi que
finalement monsieur bord elle proposera
quelques sanctions personnelles contre
des ddd des russes qui ont des
responsabilités directes personnel dans
le traitement de monsieur navalni soit
dans son empoisonnement soit dans son
jugement soit dans son emprisonnement
mais en tout état de cause la faire sans
les faits évoqués au conseil européen de
mars est comme gelée dit avant-hier il
est très probable que la présidence
française
il exercera dans l'union européenne au
début de l'année prochaine et au début
2022 proposera d'ici neuf ou dix mois
bien les résultats de dédier des du
dialogue qui a été montée pour trouver
comment on pourrait faire progresser la
sécurité en europe et comment on
pourrait rétablir la confiance en europe
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la sphère julie ses
agresseurs présumés sont poursuivis pour
atteinte sexuelle
la cour de cassation dira le 17 mars si
elle requalifier les faits en vient
d'aggraver dans le sillage les
nombreuses affaires de violences
sexuelles révélés ces derniers mois
le garde des sceaux a annoncé que le
gouvernement souhaitait changer la loi
afin de mieux punir les crimes sexuels
sur mineurs
[Musique]
avec le climat ou encore la crise
sanitaire la crise économique est l'un
des principaux défis qui attendent joe
biden nous avons plus de 20 millions de
personnes qui perçoivent des indemnités
de chômage maintenant le plan de
monsieur byden ne remet pas les gens au
travail ici probable soit vous avez
extinction de la croissance totalement
ou alors vous laisser filer la monnaie
et tout d'un coup vous allez vous
retrouver comme au venezuela ou ailleurs
nous avons besoin d'une reconstruction
économique massive et ni monsieur trump
ni monsieur biden ne semble capable ou
désireux de le faire
c'est la même politique avec la même
avec la même vision des choses c'est à
dire l'amérique d'abord
[Musique]
et
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise
lorsque c'est arrivé cette histoire
personne ne prenait pas au sérieux nos
pieds il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
compris a pris les choses en main mais
c'est presque inévitable que l'on met
tout le monde dans le même panier et à
dire que la boîte de nuit le bistrot de
quartier à quelles conditions pierre
gagna allons nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les
restos c'est pas les clés mon jeu je
produis je travaille je sais c'est de
faire au mieux c'est aussi tout un
questionnement sur la société sur le
rapport à la solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le manque dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe run était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras
si tout se déroule comme l'envisageait
donald trump et ses négociateurs 2020
n'aura pas été seulement l'année de
lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 10 février la
cour de cassation rendra son arrêt
aujourdhui son examen après son examen
du pourvoi de julie une affaire de
violences sexuelles qui oppose une jeune
femme a vingt pompiers de paris qu'elle
accuse de l'avoir violé quand elles
avaient entre 13 et 15 ans jusqu alors
la justice a toujours requalifier les
faits en étant de sexuel évoquant le
consentement de la jeune fille
le garde des sceaux a annoncé hier que
tout acte de pénétration sexuelle
commise sur un mineur de moins de 15 ans
par un adulte sera regagnée fier de viol
donald trump füle incitateur en chef de
l'assaut meurtrier du capitole le 6
janvier accuse le chef des procureurs
démocrate au deuxième jour de son procès
historique au sénat américain
les avocats de l'ancien président
demandé son arrêt argon qu'on ne juge
pas un président qui n'est plus en
fonction
mais la procédure a été validé hier par
le sénat à majorité démocrate
le peuple égyptien se soulever il y a
dix ans avec la place tahrir comme
épicentre conduisant à la destitution
d'hosni moubarak au pouvoir depuis 1981
depuis le pays a connu de nombreux
soubresauts politiques aujourd'hui le
président al sisi suscite de vives
contestations
alerter
la cour de cassation examine et donc
aujourd'hui la requalification du statut
des agresseurs de julie la jeune fille
agressée sexuellement par vingt pompiers
plus de précision avec notre reporter
4,7 pique nique
c'était une date clé dans la sphère de
julie qui accuse une vingtaine de
pompiers de l'avoir violée à partir de
l'âge de 13 ans son pourvoi en cassation
était examinée aujourd'hui en jeu la
requalification en atteinte sexuelle en
2019 par le tribunal de versailles alors
que les pompiers étaient initialement
poursuivis pour viol
et bien finalement l'avocate générale a
conseillé de casser l'arrêt de
versailles ce qui donnerait ou partie
raison à julie je vous propose d'écouter
l'avocat des pompiers concernés et
l'avocate de la jeune fille mes clients
ne doivent pas être regardés comme des
personnes qui aujourd'hui sortirait
indemne de la situation je les dis et je
le rappelle mes clients sont renvoyés
devant le tribunal correctionnel pour
des atteintes sexuelles
cela n'est pas anodin et aujourd'hui
venir remettre en cause une
qualification pour faire valoir pour
prétendre qu'il y aurait impunité de mes
clients est largement contestable faut
évidemment renvoyé pour une grande
remise à plat ce dossier devant la
chambre de l'instruction qu'il faut
évidemment avoir une autre méthodologie
de compréhension de la d2 de la
définition du viol ont ce qu'on vient
demander en réalité c'est ce qui est
actuellement dans les débats actuels
c'est de venir encadrer un peu plus par
l'interprétation de la cour de cassation
dont c'est le rôle de venir contrôler le
droit et de donner une méthodologie aux
juridictions qui sont en dessous d'elle
pour faire bonne application application
cohérente de la norme ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui parce qu on est
évidemment dans une société où seuls 1%
des victimes de viols obtiennent justice
il y a plus de dix ans pompiers étaient
intervenus pour julie une jeune fille
déprécie fragile de 13 ans ils s'étaient
revus et les relations sexuelles
s'étaient enchaînés dégénérant pratique
de groupe sur des capots de voitures
dans des parkings et même dans l'hôpital
psychiatrique dans lequel julie était
traitée alors l'avocat de la jeune fille
a interpellé la cour accomplir des actes
pornographiques à la demande des adultes
n'est pas le consentement
cette fameuse notion de consentement qui
sera prochainement débattu à l'assemblée
en tout cas cette affaire en tout point
sordide à mobiliser les citoyens
ils sont venus hier soutenir juliet sa
mère et encore ce matin un regroupement
de féministes a été rapidement dispersée
par les forces de l'ordre
nous avons avant cela l'interviewer
claire charlès présidente des effrontées
les gens soient bien
il est fait que c'est aussi des viols
que pour une gamine de 13 ans peuvent
être consentante que bien sûr que si on
semble
les éléments tels c'est la contrainte
sont là avec des pompiers qui avaient 20
ans qui était en situation d'autorité
sur une jeune fille qui qui prenait des
médicaments qui n'était pas bien qui
était n'était pas en état de consentir
donc oui c'est là que je vous dis qu'il
ya un gouffre en fait entre l'évolution
de la société et le côté archaïque des
institutions dans lequel il faut
vraiment mettre un grand coup pour que
pour que pour ça ça change quoi et dans
cette affaire qui dure depuis plus de
dix ans le délibéré concernant le prouve
en cassation sera rendu le 17 mars et
cette affaire julie s'ajoute à d'autres
affaires plus médiatiques viol inceste
pédophilie la parole semble se libérer
depuis plusieurs mois y compris dans des
cercles très fermés celui notamment de
sciences po par exemple avec la sphère
du ml face aux témoignages de victimes
qui se multiplient et qui se font plus
fort le gouvernement à présenter des
propositions pour mieux lutter contre
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles sur
mineurs le silence et ils arment des
puissants dans ces affaires de viols
assistons à une prise de conscience
réelle c'est l'objet de notre décryptage
ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vanessa saaba rédactrice en chef du
magazine psychoenfants vice présidente
d'enfance majuscule bonsoir vanessa sa
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
pascal cuisine avocat président de
l'association coup de pouce protection
de l'enfance bonsoir m musique merci
d'être venus également donc chaque jour
en ce moment une révélation choc qui
donne la nausée en matière d'inceste ou
de violences sexuelles sur mineurs
les français sont sous le choc il n'y a
pas d'autre mot vanessa saab la question
qu'on peut se poser pourquoi seulement
maintenant alors que pour je dirais pas
la plupart mais en tout cas de ces
affaires très médiatique on apprend que
ç'a eu lieu il ya des années pourquoi on
sort du silence maintenant ces
révélations maintenant je crois qu'il ya
quelque chose vraiment de l'ordre du
culturel c'est à dire que oui ça vous
avez raison ça fait abstrait ça fait des
années et des années que ces affaires
sont dans les familles sont sont
enterrés dans le silence et je crois que
que ya ses fans qui se lève ces femmes
qui décident de parler il ya une
mouvement mis tous maintenant le
mouvement me points c'est ce qui est
suivi par ce mouvement sur un sport que
sur les réseaux sociaux
peut-être que les réseaux sociaux
facilitent aussi la libération de la
parole parce qu'il ya une forme
d'anonymat
pour certains tous les cas et donc oui
il ya quand même un mouvement de société
qui se lèvent face à à la hâte à la
lourdeur du silence c'est sûr alors ce
sont bien évidemment aussi à les
révélations de camille kouchner qui a
accusé on le rappelle son beau-père
médiatique le journaliste
constitutionnaliste olivier duhamel
d'avoir violé son frère jumeau qui ont
été un tournant pas un cas isolé
malheureusement on va regarder ces
chiffres ensemble d'après l'institut
ipsos en 2020 un français sur dix ce
chiffre est vertigineux affirme avoir
été victime d'inceste 6,7 millions de
français précisément déclare avoir été
victime d'inceste en 2021
depuis 2009 les chiffres de l'inceste en
france ont triplé pascal cusine
l'inceste est un phénomène tabou donc
on ne mesure n'est pas dont on ne mesure
pas l'ampleur
ben je crois que la difficulté aussi
c'est qu'on ne veut pas voir parce que
les enquêtes sur ce fléau qu'est
l'inceste elle existe depuis longtemps
et et moi je suis étonné aujourd'hui
quand on entend les prises de paroles de
monsieur attaquer et de monsieur dupont
moretti
dernièrement de voir à quel point
l'inceste et l'oublié du débat quoi
c'est à dire qu'on souhaite poser un
interdit en retenant un seuil d'âge à 15
ans mais on oublie le cas de l'inceste
comme si comme s'il ya 15 ans et un jour
un enfant pouvait consentir à un acte
incestueux donc donc ce fléau blain c
est ce qu on connait on a déjà les
chiffres qui sont effrayants du nombre
de victimes
il est temps maintenant que les
politiques regardent ça en face et
prenne des dispositions pour qu'on sorte
d'un système qui est un système de quasi
impunité des violences sexuelles sur
mineurs en général on va en reparler
pascal cuisine évidemment c'est très
intéressant puisque le gouvernement
semble alors vous justement vous ne dis
pas qu'ils sont non pas mais tout de
même il ya eu des réactions politiques
et légales on va en reparler dans
quelques instants mais je voudrais
rebondir justement sur ce silence
vanessa saab qui est assourdissant ce
silence parce que quand on s'intéresse à
ces affaires on se rend compte cette
phrase terrible que tout le monde entre
guillemets savez ça dit quoi ce silence
et notamment jusqu'à dans l'entourage
en fait ce silence il est presque
générique c'est à dire qu'ils se posent
dont les familles concernant l'inceste
ça se pose quand ça touche toutes les
institutions l'église l'enseignement la
science po je dirais même ça touche les
parlementaires l'état tout ce qui est
sous forme d'institution finalement le
silence permet de tenir l'institution et
donc quand les victimes de violence
quelle qu'elle soit prise et préserve
l'institution et à l'agresseur qui a k
qui a une de la deûle emprise sur lui
qu'il ya de la domination sur lui et du
coup la victime elle veut aussi
préserver l'institution et quand on est
témoin comme la dans cette affaire
frédéric millions qu'il a su en 2018
eh bien il préfère penser enfin préfère
ne pas croire ce qu'on lui a dit et
pensé autre chose pour préserver
l'institution donc on est dans un
système qui préserve institutions que ce
soit l'institution familiale tous types
d'institutions et on a beaucoup de mal à
avancer aujourd'hui comme le disait
pascal cul sic concernant la protection
des mineurs parce que là encore il ya
tout un système de pouvoir c'est très
compliqué d'avancer sur des choses
essentielles
parce que l'institution est à préserver
avant tout parce quelques usines jusqu'à
présent c'est évidemment à l'avocat que
je m'adresse cette impunité vont dont
vous parliez c'est ça qui a favorisé
aussi ce silence la loi n'était pas du
tout adaptée et laissait finalement la
victime dans un isolement très cruel
c'est sûr que quand quand les victimes
savent que leur parole va être remise en
doute systématiquement et qu'on va
discuter systématiquement dans des
affaires de viol de leurs consentements
possible ça n'incite pas beaucoup alerté
la justice et a déposé plainte
on en avait on a encore jusqu'à ce jour
un système juridique qui oblige les
tribunaux dans chaque affaire de viol a
discuté de la question de la contrainte
et du consentement possible de l'enfant
les magistrats le font quotidiennement
parce que la loi n'impose parce que
quand on ouvre le code pénal français on
se rend compte que la contrainte et à
caractériser y compris lorsqu'il s'agit
d'un enfant victime très jeunes ou d'un
enfant victime d'inceste
donc cette question de la contrainte
aléas les récurrentes danser dans ces
débats on le voit dans la sphère julie
dont vous avez parlé dans votre
reportage et est forcément que
ça donne un système qui offre en quelque
sorte une une voie royale aux agresseurs
vers l'impunité et c'est de ce système
là que l'opinion publique ne veut plus
aujourd'hui parce qu'on se rend bien
compte que discuter du consentement d'un
enfant de 6 ans ou dix huit ans ou même
d'un enfant plus jeune lorsqu'il est
victime de son père ou de son grand
frère par exemple c'est un défi au bon
sens et le droit ne peut pas à ce point
est déconnecté des réalités
vanessa sable une application justement
avant de parler de cet aspect très légal
qui va être important à ces prochaines
années vous parler de ce hashtag ainsi
en sport la parole qui se délient
doucement les démissions des uns et des
autres notamment du directeur de de
sciences po ça veut dire quoi que ce
cette omerta elle était particulièrement
dans ces milieux très très élitiste on a
tous évidemment beaucoup ont lu ce livre
de camille imaginaire s'il ya des
mécanismes ayant des mécanismes
d'emprise c'est à dire que en fait dans
toutes ces affaires là et elle en parle
très bien qu ami kouchner dans son livre
elle était sous le charme de dieu hamel
mais au-delà de ça le silence il vient
aussi l'omerta elle vient de ce système
d'emprise où finalement ben en face on a
il ya un fait un faible et hier un fort
il ya un sachant il ya un apprenant et
il y a y'a comme ça dans toutes les
institutions il y à un système comme ça
d'emprise où il y en a un qui sont
inférieures à l'autre et ça et ça permet
le silence c'est à dire que en fait
l'autre sachant mieux ce qu'il faut
faire quand il nous dit qu'il faut qu'il
faut se taire et ben il faut se taire et
cali kouchner à la la la elle a mis
beaucoup d'années à écrire ce livre a
attendu la mort de sa mère pour écrire
ce livre et on voit bien que dans tout
chez toutes les victimes
parler c'est un travail qui se fait
qu'ils aient de qui prend des années
souvent on s'étonne on dit tiens elle a
parlé 30 ans où il a parlé quarante ans
après mais en réalité c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement compliqué
parce que il ya des systèmes de loyauté
il ya des systèmes de
à l'intérieur de ces agressions de
silence aussi qui protège la victime de
silence qui protège l'agresseur c'est
très complexe sur le plan psychologique
et l'emprise c'est très complexe parce
que justement ça mélange tout ça et
qu'il faut des années pour en sortir
fois avoir une maturité avoir fait peut
parfois un travail psychologique pour
arriver en sortir alors pascal cuisine
face à ce phénomène vous le disiez le
gouvernement veut toucher aux seuils
d'âge ce sera 15 ans a dit hier le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti est ce que l'introduction d'un
âge minimum de consentement en france
suffira-t-il à protéger ses enfants
contre les abus sexuels m alors
l'introduction d'un seuil d'âge de non
consentement est absolument
indispensable pour pour enfin
contrairement à ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure qu'on ne discute plus de
la question de la contrainte
concernant des mineurs de moins de 15
ans maintenant par rapport à l' annonce
qui a été faite par le gouvernement sur
ce seuil d'âge de 15 ans je serais pas
aussi affirmatif que vous sur le fait
que ce sera effectivement à saint gildas
de 15 ans parce que on nous a sorti du
chapeau hier une nouvelle condition qui
serait la différence d'âge de 5 ans
entre l'agresseur et la victime
donc ça veut dire que si l'agresseur à
18 ans et qu'un jour et que lille
agresse sexuellement une jeune femme par
exemple de 14 ans et bah ça ne rentrera
pas dans la nouvelle infraction qui a
été annoncé puisqu'il n'ya pas les cinq
ans d'écart d'âge donc son annonce en
grande pompe un seuil d'âge à 15 ans
mais on se rend compte en introduisant
comme ça des exceptions comme celle ci
est cette condition de l'écart d'âge on
se rend compte qu'en réalité de fait le
vrai seuil de non consentement il va
plutôt est à 13 ans est-ce qu'il ya que
en dessous de 13 ans quand se posera
jamais la question de la contrainte donc
je trouve ça presque cynique de la part
du gouvernement d'aller annoncer un
seuil à 15 ans et et de rajouter une
condition qui fait qu'en réalité
le seuil véritable y sera plutôt à 13 et
cette condition de différence d'âge va
poser une multitude de problèmes parce
que si on ne réglemente pas le cas de
l'inceste
ça veut dire que un grand frère de 17
ans pourrait agressé sa petite soeur de
14 ans et demi il n'ya pas les 50
différence d'âge
donc ça ne sera pas considéré comme un
crime et puis indépendamment des cas
d'inceste encore une fois voilà un jeune
majeur de 18 ans qui agresse une mineure
qui a entre 13 et 15
ça ne sera pas non plus considéré comme
un crime et on ne sait même pas
d'ailleurs si si ça sera encore
considéré comme un délit venez donc sa
peau tannée sa monde oui oui faire ta
mine et battra jeffrey réagir aussi ben
effaçable sa pause oui là je disais que
ça allait poser d'énormes difficultés
juridiques et que là où on est censé
poser un interdit fort et clair en
ouvrant autant d'exceptions
eh ben on pose un interdit qui n'est
plus du tout fort et qui n'est plus du
tout clair vanessa sable vous voyez
sourire vous quand j'ai cité cette loi
de sortie du chapeau de d'eric
dupond-moretti efficace ou pas selon
vous ben je je suis d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire monsieur cul sic et
surtout ce ça me fait réagit en disant
mais comment se fait-il que encore
aujourd'hui on est à se battre et
d'ailleurs ça fait des années moi je
fais donc je suis présidente d'enfance
majuscule aussi qui est une association
de protection des enfants qui existe
depuis 1956 et on se bat bec et ongles
pour obtenir des textes qui sont là pour
protéger nos enfants et on se rend bien
compte que là aussi à une préservation
d'une institution et à une lenteur
étatique il ya une difficulté étatiques
à protéger les enfants
donc c'est pour ça que je souriais parce
que ça revient à ceux dont je parlais
qui est que ce système en fait d'omerta
ceci ce système de dénis parce qu'on a
eu un mépris de l'unss est très fort et
donc on n'a pas non plus de mesures sur
l'inceste encore très clair annoncées
par le gouvernement
donc le système de dénis il est
générique il est global et touche les
familles et touche l'état il touche les
toutes les institutions et touche
sciences po donc je souriais à cause de
ça c'est parce qu'on a
on n'a pas encore on n'est pas encore
arrivé au bout on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge janvier
justement vous me tendez la perche pour
la prochaine question pourquoi la france
at-elle autant tardé aborder ces lois ce
consentement ce débat sur l'âge du
consentement parce que tous les autres
pays occidentaux ont une oie sur l'âge
du consentement pascal musique pourquoi
autant de temps en france un pays
supposés quand même moderne mais si
c'est une très bonne question je suis
pas sûr d'avoir la réponse
ce que je constate simplement c'est que
en 2018 lorsque la question avait déjà
été soulevée au moment du vote de la loi
schiappa on avait entendu de belles
déclarations d'intention sur le fait
qu'il ne fallait plus que le
consentement de l'enfant soit au coeur
du débat devant les tribunaux on s'est
rendu compte que la loi schiappa n'avait
en fait en rien transcrit dans la loi
les bennes annonce qui avait été fait en
renvoyant systématiquement la notion de
discernement donc toujours un examen au
cas par cas et là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est en train de revivre un épisode
un peu similaire c'est à dire qu'on fait
de belles annonces sur un seuil de 15
ans et puis on nous introduit des
exceptions sur la connaissance de l'âge
sur la différence d'âge entre l'auteur
et la victime qui va finir par vider de
sa substance le l'interdît fort et clair
qu'on était censé poser donc
donc on est dans cette difficulté de de
constater que malgré les belles
déclarations d'intention au moment de
passer à l'acte il ya toujours une
difficulté pour que les choses soient
transcrite dans dans la loi
alors que certains pays ont résolu cette
question depuis longtemps en angleterre
il ya un âge de deux non consentement
depuis 60 ans donc on a on a un retard
considérable sur la question de nombreux
pays l'allemagne la belgique le canada
la tunisie depuis 2010 est ont adopté
des âges de non consentement
parfaitement clair sans prévoir une
multitude d'exception qui ne sont là que
pour protéger les adultes donc
je ne comprends pas qu'on ne soit pas en
mesure nous de regarder un petit peu ce
qui se passe ailleurs et de s'inspirer
des des autres droits pour enfin avoir
une système de protection de l'enfance
qui soit digne de ce nom
mais manifestement on n'aura pas la
réponse aujourd'hui vanessa saab
une de mes dernières questions qu'est ce
qui est prévu du côté de la victime pour
la reconstruction
justement de ces victimes souvent isolés
qu'est ce qui est prévu sur le plan
légal
will d'une manière générale est ce qu on
a parlé de la répression du côté de la
loi en france
pour l'auteur des faits mais est ce que
la douleur de la victime ait pris
suffisamment en compte dans notre pays
et sa reconstruction surtout non je
crois qu'on mesure pas encore
concrètement finalement les impacts je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
comprennent pas quel est l'impact
psychologique des agressions sexuelles
sur sur les mineurs et sur les femmes
les traumatismes que ça génère les
effractions psychique les
déstabilisations ya pas de prise en
charge qui est organisé par l'état
malheureusement donc c'est les
associations qui met ça en place
moi j'aimerais bien rebondir sur votre
question quand même qui est que la
france a des spécificités par rapport
aux autres pays
camille kouchner en parle il ya mai 68
qui explique un certain nombre de choses
il ya aussi la place de la psychanalyse
en france en france et et ça c'est
singulier il n'y a que deux pays
youtube qui donne à la psychanalyse
cette place-là et et avec tout ce que la
psychanalyse peut comporter tout ce
qu'elle a pu aider mais c'est tout ce
qu'elle a pu comporter aujourd'hui qui
est dépassé aussi avec le fantasme des
enfants la notion de l'oedipe qui a
évolué qui est plus exactement celle qui
existait donc tout ce courant libertaire
est encore là et en fait le droit
français est encore très marquée par
tout ce courant libertaire je pense que
pascal cul sic ne me contredira pas mais
beaucoup d'experts c'est des
psychanalystes qui sont entendus par les
tribunaux dans les affaires et ça ça
ralentit énormément là ça ralentit la
prise en charge ça crée des impunités
sacré des ont dit que l'enfant était
peut-être qu'on s'entend donc tout ça
c'est dépassé et il ya quelque chose à
faire aussi sur un plan psychologique de
manière globale et sur sur lesquels sont
les experts entendus devant les
tribunaux faudrait qu'ils aient un
expert pluridisciplinaire des experts
pluridisciplinaires mai mais c'est pas
possible aujourd'hui de 2
née la voie qu'il ya eu un seul un seul
courant de psychologie maderna question
est le mode f1 pour vous pascal cuisine
une prise de conscience réellement y
aura un avant et un après je vois bien
ma première question avec l'espoir
peut-être de loi qui évolue évidemment
de répression bien d'en parler mais
aussi dans le sens de la victime
l'espoir oui bien sûr on l'a et puis il
notamment en voyant que des propositions
de loi avait été déposée par madame
santiago notamment ou même par madame
alexandra louis qui préconise de retenir
un seuil d'âge à 15 ans et un seuil
d'âge à 18 ans en cas d'inceste sans
multiplier à côté des exceptions donc
l'espoir oui il existe et on se dit que
la france va pas pouvoir être
perpétuellement à la traîne de ses
voisins maintenant on a appris à être
extrêmement vigilant parce que ça soit
en 2018 ou ou compte tenu des annonces
qui ont été faites hier
je crois que la vigilance est de mise
parce que on se rend compte qu'il ya
encore de grands grands mouvements de de
réticence à adopter une vraie culture de
protection de l'enfant merci en tout cas
tous les deux vanessa saab
pascal cuisine d'avoir été avec no mercy
quelques instants rester avec nous nous
reviendrons sur le procès en destitution
de donald trump celui qui fut
l'instigateur en chef de l'assaut
meurtrier du capitole 6 janvier accuse
le chef des producteurs des pauvretés
procureur démocrate au deuxième jour et
puis direction l'egypte après
dix ans de révolution populaire ayant
conduit à la destitution d'hosni
moubarak
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent
ça n en soit vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'indiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes
le son il est l'âme on les a déjà trop
de dépenses trop d'état je pense en tout
cas qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie c'est
à dire un état inefficace tout ça a été
financée essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique et est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
souligné roselyne france quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre l'eau politiques et les experts
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde vivre
avec la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez le
procès en destitution de donald trump
est bien conforme à la constitution
deuxième jour d'audience et le chef des
procureurs démocrates accusent donald
trump füle incitateur en chef de
l'assaut meurtrier du capitole le 6
janvier les avocats de l'ancien
président ont eux dénoncent un procès
politique les précisions de walid
bennani une ligne droite pour aller
droit au but neuf procureurs démocrates
bien haut rang pour en découdre
les avocats de donald trump
suivent derrière un procès historique
pour une introduction tout aussi
marquantes
oui
sénateurs le président a été mis en
accusation par la chambre des
représentants des états unis le 13
janvier dernier pour avoir fait cela
vous vous demandez ce qu'est un crime ou
un délit élevé selon notre constitution
c'est un crime et un délit grave si ce
n'est pas un délit impénitent alors il
n'y a rien de tel
les démocrates ont choisi de rappeler à
la chambre haute du parlement
l'effet du 6 janvier 2021 lorsque les
supporters de donald trump avait envahi
le capitole le clan démocrate affichant
également un tweet du 45e président des
états unis
deux heures après l'attaqué ce dernier
appelé les manifestants à rentrer chez
eux tout en les saluant chaleureusement
ricamarie date with me comme chaque fois
que je dis ce tweet
ça me fait froid dans le dos le
président des états unis s'est rangé du
côté des insurgés
il a salué leur cause il a validé leurs
attaques
il leur a dit souvenez-vous de ce jour
porte toujours fragile entre les
présidents ne peuvent pas déclencher une
insurrection dans leurs dernières
semaines et s'en allait ensuite comme si
rien ne s'était passé une première
journée marquée par une question peut-on
juger ou non un désormais ex-président
un simple citoyen selon les mots des
avocats de donald trump ce procès
déchirera ce pays d'une façon que nous
n'avons vu qu'une seule fois
précédemment dans notre histoire
en réalité nous sommes ici car la
majorité à la chambre des représentants
ne veut pas affronter donald trump comme
rival politique à l'avenir c'est la
vraie raison pour laquelle nous sommes
ici
si donald trump été reconnu coupable le
milliardaire républicain ne pourrait
plus briguer la maison blanche dans
quatre ans d'ailleurs son actuel
locataire joe biden n'entend pas
commenter les différents échanges de ce
procès beaucoup de familles sont en
insécurité alimentaire elles sont en
difficulté c'est ça mon travail le sénat
à son travail il est sur le point de le
commencer et je suis sûr qu'ils vont
bien se conduire et c'est tout ce que
j'ai à dire sur la destitution
cette fameuse question de
constitutionnalité finalement tranché à
la fin de cette première journée
les cinquante sénateurs démocrates et
six sénateurs républicains ont estimé
que le procès pouvait bien se poursuivre
et du ray mercredi place à l'exposé des
faits chaque camp dispose d'un maximum
de 16 heures pour convaincre et pour en
parler nous sommes avec l jean-claude
bonjour vice président du cercle de
réflexion france amérique
bonsoir jean claude beaujour merci à
d'un chat avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors les pros avant vont
démontrer que donald trump a abandonné
son rôle de commandant en chef pour
devenir lé incitateur en chef d'une
dangereuse insurrection ce sont les mots
du procureur démocrate
de quelles preuves parle-t-il été je
pense que à ce stade une chose qui est
certaine et nous avons vu dans l'open
space menthe du camp du procureur
démocrate des représentants de la
chambre des représentants
nous avons vu la première vidéo la vidéo
de l'attak d'une part ça c'est le fait
et deuxièmement qu'il faut absolument
lié ce sont les propos du président et
donc je pense qu'au cours de ce procès
ce corps affaire l'accusation c'est de
lier les propos aux faits aux actes
illicites qui ont été commis et de faire
endosser à donald trump une
responsabilité directe ça sera ça le
travail des du procureur de l'accusation
de véritablement de rendre donald trump
directement responsables des actes qui
ont été commis
et puis en face on vous expliquera et je
pense que c'est ce que tentera de faire
la défense la défense tentera de dire le
président n'a jamais dit directement à
ses supporters d'aller marque de non
seulement d'aller au au capitole mais en
plus d'avoir le comportement qu'il a eu
d'ailleurs vous dire à vous diront ses
avocats très rapidement et par la suite
je quelques jours après il a indiqué que
ce sont des comportements qui n'étaient
pas normaux qu'il demandait que c'était
que l'amérique c'est un état de droit
etc etc
on voit bien que ce qui sera apprécié
par les sénateurs c'est la ligne
véritablement extrêmement ténue sur
laquelle s'est situé donald trump le
jour ce 6 janvier
alors on le sait que cette procédure de
destitution un peu de chances d'aboutir
dans le fond jean claude beaujour quel
en est l'enjeu un enjeu d'image aussi
pour donald trump alors pas seulement
tout d'abord il faut il faut malgré tout
attendre même si il y a peu de chances
que le camp démocrate arrive à rallier
les 17 c'est les 17 sénateurs manquant
pour pouvoir faire une majorité de 60 %
il y à une deuxième chance et que si
évidemment fonction d'évolutions du
procès donald trump pourrait sortir son
image pourrait sortir extrêmement est
écornée mais dans le même temps ça peut
raviver la division américaine et
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
le président baden ne souhaitait pas ce
procès la conséquence peut-être de rang
de raviver le véritablement la
polarisation de la société américaine
la conséquence peut-être aussi de faire
exploser définitivement le parti
républicain
peut-être que certains nombre de
républicains souhaitent se débarrasser
définitivement de donald trump
mais dans le même temps n'oublions pas
que sur les 72 74 millions d'électeurs
qui ont voté pour donald trump
ce dernier a au moins une vingtaine de
millions de supporters extrêmement actif
et qui seront se faire entendre dans des
prochains scrutins
à commencer par le scrutin qu'il y aura
dans 2 1 qui verront un certain nombre
de candidats républicains probablement
en difficulté donc vous voyez l'enjeu
n'est pas simplement juridique n'est pas
simplement judiciaire mais l'idée lui
est aussi politique et social pour la
démocratie américaine car justement
david janin des avocates donald trump a
estimé que ce procès était je cite une
instrumentalisation politique de la
procédure de destitution qui allez je
cite pour rejoindre vos mots d'ailleurs
déchiré le pays qui est déjà très
divisée
on le sait les américains finalement ne
sont pas dupes de cette
instrumentalisation
je pense tout d'abord que les
américaines très rapidement penseront et
pensent à autre chose vous savez pour
tous ceux qui ici ou là sont de la
famille aux états unis où séjourne aux
états unis la préoccupation des
américains comme elle est la
préoccupation des français aujourd'hui
c'est deux à de retrouver un emploi et
il a le sujet est prégnant aux états
unis donc que ce sont ces le plan que va
mettre en place
joe biden au cours de ses 100 premiers
jours c'est le plan de quasiment 2 mille
milliards qui est sur la table qui est
en discussion parce que les gens ont
besoin d'un emploi les gens veulent
éviter d'être expulsés de leur logement
ils veulent pouvoir avoir accès pour
ceux qui sont malades c'est cela la
préoccupation des américains aujourd'hui
parce qu'il n'aura échappé à personne
que nous vivons tous une situation très
exceptionnelle avec le coronavirus est
quasiment malheureusement mais quasiment
un demi million de personnes on est on
est con qu'on commence à approcher des
cinq cent mille décès aux états unis qui
font des états unis le pays qui aura
payé le plus lourd tribut en termes de
décès donc on voit bien que la
préoccupation des américains et les
autres elle et elle est déjà je pense
qu'on a déjà quasiment d'une certaine
manière on peut tourner la page de
donald trump en tout cas pour ceux qui
ont des préoccupations basiques comme
c'est le cas de chacun d'entre nous
aujourd'hui vous parler du committee est
évidemment est logiquement la
préoccupation numéro un il se trouve
tout de même qu'on soit fan ou non de
donald trump soutien ou non d'un an 30
avait annoncé le vaccin avant novembre
ce qui avait provoqué quelques
ricanements aux états unis mais ailleurs
également est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
américains lui font crédit quand même
d'avoir le vrai en tout cas mis les
milliards nécessaires pour que ce vaccin
soit prêt aussitôt j'ai le sentiment que
messi c'est pas simplement lié à
situation américaine ou simplement lié à
situation de oca donald trump nos
concitoyens et les personnes concernées
attendent surtout de retrouver un
semblant
de vie normale à la fois pour ceux dont
on a parlé qui sont les pubertés en
étant soit malade trois décédés mais
aussi tous ceux qui n'ont pas d'emploi
aujourd'hui et vous savez qu'il ya eu
jusqu'à honda on a commencé à réduire le
chômage aux etats-unis mais tout ça est
un peu et particulièrement d'un taux de
chômage particulièrement élevé pour
toutes ces raisons je pense que s'il
doit y avoir un crédit accordé à tel ou
tel président que ce soit le sortant que
ce soit le nouveau c'est lorsque la dent
dans sa grande majorité la population
américaine
on recommencera à vivre lorsque
l'amérique va réouvrir aujourd'hui les
écoles sont fermées
le pays est fermée donc vous voyez c'est
une situation qui à la fois sur le plan
économique sur le plan social est
extrêmement compliqué et c'est à ce
moment là on est vraiment sur une
situation où on attend des résultats que
tout plutôt que des annonces là pour le
coup les annonces ne suffisent pas merci
beaucoup pour votre amène son lot de
bons jours d'avoir été avec nous en tout
cas merci à vous une centaine de cubains
en demande à joe biden de lever
l'embargo américain des artistes des
universitaires ou encore des
entrepreneurs lui ont adressé une lettre
ouverte ils pointent du doigt les
sanctions imposées par l'administration
trump qui est grave
cet embargo cette requête intervient
quelques jours après le dépôt d'un
projet de loi par un sénateur démocrate
pour demander précisément sa levée et
l'établissement de relations
commerciales normales entre les deux
pays et coûté kelo marque look et une au
sol au cas où l'action film awards
le plus probable est qu'il n'y ait pas
une seule action d'entreprise mais
plusieurs et les plus importantes sont
les suivantes premièrement comme je le
disais sortir cuba de la liste des pays
terroristes car c'est une image fausse
une fausse idée de cuba cuba est un pays
en transition il
certes des problèmes de droits de
l'homme mais sa présence sur la liste
des pays terroristes n'est qu'un
instrument politique nord américains
servant à critiquer a dénoncé la
deuxième mesure importante serait
l'autorisation de voyager cette
ouverture des voyages pourraient
permettre l'engagement de la population
dans cette interaction entre la société
cubaine et celles d'amérique du nord
comme des loups comme et ses
interactions sociales ou à la note
américaine et au blocage c'est lourd et
je pense qu'en troisième lieu s'il
décide de rétablir les voyages il serait
incohérent de ne pas ouvrir les lignes
nord-américaine aérienne au delà des
vols à destination de la havane mais
dans toutes les capitales de province
qui ont des aéroports ok nogué mais
thank you
parce que ça n'aurait pas de sens
d'ouvrir une zone et de perdre les
bénéfices qui seraient engendrés par
cette nouvelle relation un engagment
comme on dit en anglais afin de rétablir
un contact avec l'ensemble de la société
cubaine et un argentine des centaines de
personnes étaient rassemblées
aujourd'hui à buenos aires élèves
professeurs parents les argentins ont
manifesté pour un retour en classe dans
un contexte sanitaire et économique
lourd
les explications de maxime abers cela
fait bientôt un an un an qu'ils n'ont
plus vu de tableau noir nous demandons
un retour en classe en présentiel
après une année sans mettre les pieds à
l'école les conséquences psychologiques
et physiques sont importantes tout comme
sur le travail ainsi que les familles un
million et demi d'enfants ont d'abord
donné leur scolarité
depuis le début de la pandémie tous les
niveaux sont concernés de la maternelle
à l'université
aucune salle de classe n'a pu ouvrir
sauf dérogation ce mardi les argentins
se sont donc réunis devant le ministère
de l'éducation à buenos aires pour
protester contre une fermeture qui n'en
finit plus
je me sens loin de mes camarades de
cours c'était la dernière chance pour
moi de créer des liens avec eux et
honnêtement cela m'affecte énormément
d'un point de vue social en argentine 6
enfants sur 10 vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
ainsi les moyens mis en place comme
l'école à distance via internet ne font
qu'accroître les inégalités
si bien que 80 % des parents se disent
inquiets pour le niveau scolaire de
leurs enfants
3 million et demi d'enfants non pas une
connexion suffisante et ne pourront pas
suivre les cours ils sont déjà six mille
cinq cents rien que dans la ville de
buenos ars mais il n'y a aucun chiffre
sur la région de la capitale le
gouvernement ne veut pas les fournir la
vérité c'est qu'il est dépassé on a un
gouvernement qui ne répond jamais à nos
demandes équivaut à l'éducation comme
quelque chose qu'on peut repousser à
plus tard alors que l'om est conseillé
de garder les salles de classes ouvertes
au moment de la deuxième vague
l'incompréhension est totale pour les
argentins surtout quand leurs voisins
prennent le risque de rouvrir comme le
chili depuis le 5 octobre dernier sans
que la situation sanitaire ne s'aggrave
pour autant pris à partie le ministre de
l'éducation a voulu réagir
il est impératif que toutes les
provinces met en place un retour dans
les classes nous souhaitons promouvoir
le retour des cours en présentiel
initiée par buenos aires le 17 février
prochain
mais cela dans des conditions sûres nous
devons travailler main dans la main avec
toutes les juridictions pour assurer un
retour dans les classes avec le plus de
précaution possible à cette crise
sanitaire s'y ajoute une autre
économique cette fois sujet à une
inflation galopante le pays connaît
actuellement une hausse de 74 % du prix
de la viande
alors qu'il doit déjà restructurer une
dette avoisinant les 90 % de son pib
le président alberto fernandez a même
mis en place un impôt kovy destinés aux
plus riches pour faire face s'agissant
des vaccins l'argentine a lancé sa
campagne le 29 décembre dernier et doit
encore recevoir 19,4 millions de doses
de vaccins d'ici fin février + 5 en
option
peuplée de 44 millions d'habitants
l'argentine a pour l'heure enregistré
près de deux millions de cas qu vide 19
pour cinquante mille décès et pour ne
rien arranger le pays vient d'identifier
le variant brésilien sur son sol
et un anniversaire historique en egypte
celui les dix ans des destitutions
d'hosni moubarak demain depuis le pays a
connu de nombreux soubresauts politiques
retour sur ses aînés post
révolutionnaire avec hélène masquelier
février 2011 la colère gronde sur la
place tahrir symbole du pouvoir en plein
centre du caire
il y a dix ans le peuple égyptien se
soulevait contre le président hosni
moubarak
emboîtant ainsi le pas à la tunisie un
événement historique qui voyait émerger
de nouveaux leaders dans les rues dans
tout le pays ou sur la place tahrir les
gens manifestent avec une motivation
très forte
ils ont leurs revendications le
président devrait démissionner il doit
quitter son poste et son régime ont déjà
échoué par la volonté de ce peuple il
doit démissionner et une nouvelle ère
politique doit s'ouvrir
trois semaines seulement après le début
du mouvement le 11 février 2011 le
peuple sort vainqueur
hosni moubarak est destitué après 30 ans
au pouvoir
s'ensuit alors une période de transition
avec le mouvement islamiste des frères
musulmans et son leader mohamed morsi
une présidence d'à peine un an
écourtée en 2013 par un coup d'état les
militaires s'emparent du pouvoir et
impose le général abdel fattah al-sisi
élu président en 2014
depuis huit ans les espoirs de liberté
et de justice sociale s'aménuisent face
à un pouvoir toujours plus autoritaire
nous avons connu une nouvelle escalade
globale en termes de répression du
paysage des droits humains en général en
egypte avec l'arrestation de nos
collègues de l'initiative égyptienne
pour les droits individuels
qui est l'une des plus importantes
organisations de défense des droits
humains qui subsistent encore dans le
pays
au caire où ailleurs aucune
commémoration de l'événement n'est prévu
d'ailleurs que ce soit dans les médias
ou dans les livres
la révolution égyptienne n'a pas droit
de cité quant au gouvernement il
renforce son contrôle interdisant tout
rassemblement en particulier sur la
place tahrir
car désormais c'est la menace d'une
nouvelle révolution qui plane au dessus
du pays
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
myriam mènera politologue spécialiste du
moyen-orient bonsoir myriam merci d'être
avec nous en direct par téléphone sur
rtl france il ya donc dix ans a le mot
liberté résonné sur la place tahrir en
egypte
qu'en reste-t-il aujourd'hui bien il en
reste une société civile qui vous le
voyez pour certains segments n'a pas
renoncé à réclamer ses droits à mekla
mais surtout plus de justice locale
parce que quand on parle de droit c'est
surtout les inégalités les injustices
qui était visé par la révolution 2011
donc on a un pan de la population
égyptienne qui m'a pas qui n'est pas
résigné par rapport à cet objectif et
qui voudraient qu'une nouvelle
contestation d'ampleur prennent place
pour modifier la donne et puis on a
quand même aussi une autre partie de la
population qui allait plutôt rallié au
régime en réalité à alarmer et qui s'est
fait une raison quant à a
quant à cette révolution china qui n'a
pas apporté grand chose aux égyptiens
enfin j'ai aussi l'impression qui
prévaut chez g20 certain nombre d'entre
eux donc c'est pour ça qu'on ne voit pas
d'ailleurs de résurgence révolutionnaire
est donc ça veut dire en gros en résumé
peut-être que l'egypte s'est débarrassé
d'un homme mais pas d'un régime
non mais l'origine n'est jamais tombé en
réalité
l'état égyptien est un régime militaire
l'armée a un rôle central
historiquement par ailleurs l'egypte est
très touchée par le terrorisme donc bien
évidemment l'armée a eu des arguments
pour rétablir son contrôle après 2011
et bien évidemment même pendant la
période de pril d'arrivée du pouvoir des
frères musulmans avant la déposition de
deux mois maintenant si l'armée n'avait
pas du tout disparu du paysage
il fallait s'attendre à ce qu'elles par
cette contre révolution pour prendre les
rênes du pays
et aujourd'hui j'ai parlé du terrorisme
ne fait principal argument bien
évidemment que que les égyptiens oppose
à tout ce qui leur parle de droits
fondamentaux de droits de l'homme et de
démocratie alors selon un rapport
d'amnesty international injustement les
emprisonnements sous le gouvernement du
maréchal elle si sion ont explosé ces
dernières années est ce qu on fait face
à un gouvernement encore plus répressif
que celui de hosni moubarak
oui d'une certaine manière moi j'ai
toujours considéré que finalement
l'autoritarisme et était beaucoup plus
prononcée aujourd'hui en egypte qu'il ne
l'était pour la simple et bonne raison
que le gouvernement d'hosni moubarak
avait procédé à une ouverture à la fin à
la fin de son pouvoir alors une
ouverture très relative
mais il y avait tout de même des pas de
fait vers la société civile et puis 2001
en quelque sorte par la violence des
événements et puis la fragmentation si
la société gif scène tout cela le
terrorisme d'état islamique tout cela a
créé des tensions qui entachaient
finalement une transition je dirais
sereine vers vers un régime plus ouvert
plus qui conserve des libertés alors une
démocratie occidentale sans doute pas
mais un régime plus ouvert et ça a été
complètement mon avis remis en cause par
la suite des événements pour quelle
raison justement ça a été aussi
compliqué et remis en cause justement
pas d'une part parce que l'armée
toujours rester aux commandes en réalité
comme je lé précisé l'armée face à la
violence des événements a en quelque
sorte transiger en temps pour ensuite
reprendre la main
et donc pour chasser les frères
musulmans est dans le giron des frères
musulmans toute l'opposition en fait
ensuite on a eu des actions terroristes
extrêmement violentes et meurtrières en
egypte qui ont encore donné davantage
d'arguments aux militaires pour reha
soir leur pouvoir et se donne aussi pour
ça que beaucoup d'égyptiens aujourd'hui
soutiennent en fait le régime en disant
que voilà que que que sans ce régime
militaire sans un pouvoir fort l'egypte
va sombrer dans le chaos dans le
terrorisme
l'anarchie qui paiera et puis évidemment
les égyptiens sont très au courant qui
passe en syrie en irak en libye quel
pays voisins et et craignent par dessus
tout cette descente dans une potentielle
guerre civile en cas de de déliquescence
du pouvoir donc on fait le pari du rpt
du pouvoir fort chez certains égyptiens
on les a pas entendu d'ailleurs dans
l'eau chaude reportage mais il est
important de le dire merci menem mènera
politologue spécialiste du moyen-orient
merci d'avoir été avec nos nuits
et c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
faire un point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
la minus maël compte au moins quatorze
mille militaires et policiers déployés
au menu donc c'était le fasse
c'est une mission de paix des nations
unies
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle est connue
dans un angle difficile qu'on aura un
ennemi un ennemi invisible un ennemi
qu'il ne connaît pas de frontières qui
ne connaît que la brutalité qui est là
pour faire du mal mais grave